welcome to this blitz video playing
Jimmy the saint from yeah some of our on
down united arab emirates I always
confuse this with Scott island and
similar you sort of know that this is
the area I mean I sort of know but i
don't i'm not able to tell them apart
okay so we have a bogo type of position
um you have now it's a dutch type of
position it's just them develop here
let's see what black is coming up with
yep playing with the fianchetto b6 these
kind of positions you can also play with
d 685 not would be six aha is mixing
thanks which is a bit strange ok let's
try to directly attack it Wow now this
is really good but maybe here you can
afford it and I g5 or should I prepare
things let's play the slowly Quincy to
key one III for this kind of moose
I'm not really attacking it but it's
hard to not play g6 at some point okay
now f4 III III might I can I can play
three before I can play three med open
up the position okay yeah now i have an
excellent bishop let's see how to
continue he's got 95 to d3 that's not
the end of the world should I put a
knight on d4 yeah why not actually this
is a pretty good spot for the night yeah
to e6 on b5 let's see can I or should I
try to prepare g4 it's not a bad plan
let's go here and reposition the pieces
of it the Bishop to e2
uh-huh okay you know this makes it a bit
more difficult to play G forward wow
this I find really strange what are you
doing I mean I want to open up the Kings
side he's just doing it for me this is
really strange Queen f2 or not I'll just
take it let's just take it wait the g
far I'll have to attack there it's a bit
strange King to h2o yeah probably anyway
I came sugar from one probably yeah it's
got this Knight g4 idea this is really a
problem Knight g4
hmm wow I really am underestimated that
okay this is I think necessary to get to
get g one for the king I mean I'm pretty
sure if if you if you ask the comp it
will tell you that white is
substantially better but I didn't really
see that black gets to looks on the edge
file why should be better because I've
got the knight on d4 bishop once it is
that these pieces are just much better
and g6 is a weakness the bishop on b7 is
dead so just rookie to look G to
something like that should be excellent
in the long run he doesn't really have a
threat here or anything look to g5 for
problem Mia his dark squares are rather
weak
no I'm threatening discoveries night at
five and so on because the look on h8 is
hanging with the bishop on c3
k probably man let's just try to play
quickly not think too much maybe not at
five or something this is a move okay
just grab it and now look h2 maybe yeah
Oh cage to look III i take c 5 this
really should be deadly take f5 I mean
or maybe there's some better move even
rookie three rookie three Queen f2 just
the simple hmm now i'm not quite sure
okay yeah i think night f5 is a threat
now yeah not or not this is probably
better attacking all kinds of stuff okay
this rook f6 pin
yeah curtains nothing left black resigns
yeah the real issue was that here in
this structure black really it must just
a second like really must avoid the
structure this is just terrible cannot
allow that this Bishop is so strong Plus
this night black I really must play in
some way to avoid that like keeping this
not moving the epon I will play a form
but you must play maybe in 95 I think
black is words anyway but if always
really liked positional capitulation
almost this is this is not playable
anymore can only try to limit the damage
but this I know maybe add some some
chances because King age 2 and so on
wasn't yeah Knight g4 here we can play
that g4 here I overlooked that lagi for
yeah yeah this is this is a checkmate
yeah and 93 coming yeah hey I had the
feeling that I better screwed up here
but here are still largely form but he
doesn't do it idiots winning again no no
tricks anymore yeah this was was shaky i
played this badly yeah probably this is
still all right and here's something
else yeah compounds play be form yeah ah
here this is also a good idea actually
Bishop you one it's not the greatest
move probably but it it just covers the
spawn and make sure black doesn't get
anything here and then you have some
time to reposition the rooks to the G
file can just go here if you want and
black has no
home break anymore cannot play b5 not
see six if you don't have a pawn break
it's it's gone really and then I can
prepare to pile up on the GFR Bishop f2
look here Bishop to e2 and so on then
you can at the end them play h5 computer
actually doesn't recognize how bad this
position is it gives white something 0.6
but this is too little it's it's
actually close to winning I guess
alright thanks for watching